[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Es ist bei uns noch etwas früh am Morgen.
Okay, nicht ganz so früh, aber ich bin trotzdem müde.
Jedenfalls habe ich mir trotzdem überlegt,
heute einen Nusskuchen zu backen.
Und zwar wird das ein saftiger Schokoladen-Nuss-Kuchen,
hoffe ich zumindest.
Das Rezept probieren wir jetzt nämlich
einfach zusammen direkt aus.
Und ich denke, gerade so im Herbst
ist so ein Nusskuchen schon lecker.
Also ich bin der totale Fan von Nusskuchen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Deswegen, dachte ich, wäre das jetzt mal
ein schöner Kuchen,
den ihr auch sonntags gerne mal zubereiten könnt.
Vor allem mal wieder ein bisschen was Einfacheres.
Denn ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen, also
Torte mache ich schon ganz gerne,
aber ich esse, wenn ich Kuchen oder Torte
– also wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste,
würde ich mich schon eher für den Kuchen entscheiden,
so Linzer Torte, Nusskuchen, Schokokuchen.
Aber Torte ist auch lecker.
Aber heute gibt es Kuchen.
Okay.
Dafür nehme ich
200 Gramm weiche Butter,
200 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz
und etwas Vanilleextrakt,
sechs Eier,
– die sind bereits zimmerwarm –
250 Gramm Haselnüsse,
200 Gramm Schokoladenstreusel,
125 Gramm Mehl,
einen Teelöffel Zimt,
ein Päckchen Backpulver
– das sind drei Teelöffel –
und etwas Milch.
Statt Milch könnt ihr zum Beispiel auch
ein Gläschen Rum nehmen für das Aroma.
Aber Rum trägt auch dazu bei,
dass der Kuchen ein bisschen schöner aufgeht.
Was ich jetzt zuerst mache:
Ich nehme hier die Haselnüsse.
Die sind im Ganzen.
Und die werde ich jetzt schön fein mahlen
– oder so ein bisschen grob mahlen.
Dadurch
– also, wenn ihr ganze Nüsse nehmt, ist halt der Vorteil,
dass ihr wirklich noch das volle Aroma in den Nüssen habt.
Und dann werden sie noch angeröstet
und dann entfalten sie ihr komplettes Aroma.
Also so habt ihr wirklich den vollen Nussgeschmack.
[Musik]
Die Nüsse jetzt einfach so ein bisschen rösten ohne Fett,
bis sie lecker duften.
Immer mal wieder umrühren.
Das könnt ihr auch im Backofen machen, aber ich finde,
in der Pfanne geht es auch wirklich supereinfach.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit schon mal hier
die weiche Butter mit dem Zucker verrühren.
Und da ist wirklich bei dem Rührkuchen einfach nur wichtig,
alle Zutaten zimmerwarm zu haben,
damit eben nichts gerinnt und nichts flockt.
Zucker und Salz dazu.
Natürlich ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Und dann hier für etwa vier bis fünf Minuten cremig verrühren.
[Musik]
So sollte die Masse dann aussehen.
Also der Zucker löst sich wunderbar auf
und es ist einfach eine schöne, luftige Masse.
Jetzt gebt ihr hier die Eier einzeln dazu,
lasst jedes Ei ungefähr eine halbe Minute einrühren.
Und in der Zwischenzeit sollten auch
die Haselnüsse schon schön abkühlen.
Und ich gebe die ganze gerne
immer auf so einen Emailleteller.
Denn Emaille hat den Vorteil,
dass es die Temperatur einfach rauszieht
aus den Lebensmitteln.
Das heißt, ihr könnt Dinge schnell kalt bekommen,
ihr könnt sie schnell warm bekommen,
also je nachdem, wie ihr es eben braucht.
Und so kühlen die Haselnüsse eben
richtig gut und schnell ab.
Denn, wenn die Haselnüsse jetzt zu warm sind
und ihr sie gleich dazu gebt, schmilzt die Butter
und dann ist die ganze Luft, die ihr reingeschlagen habt,
einfach wieder weg und das wäre
ziemlich schade.
[Musik]
Na toll, jetzt sieht mein Teig auch krisselig aus.
Aber den rette ich jetzt
und zwar mit etwas Mehl.
Ich habe hier auch schon mal die trockenen Zutaten vermischt.
Die kann ich jetzt
– so ein bisschen gebe ich jetzt was rein,
damit die Masse wieder bindet.
Jetzt
– o mein Gott!
O mein Gott! Was mache ich heute?
Ich sage doch, ich bin noch zu müde.
Okay, wir brauchen keine 250 Gramm,
wir nehmen nur 230.
Mehl mit Backpulver und Zimt dazu geben.
Ach, jetzt gebe ich auch noch die Streusel rein.
Alles auf die Theke.
Die Milch noch dazu.
Wow! Das war fast eine Handvoll.
[Musik]
So.
Lieber mit Spritzschutz heute arbeiten.
Ist sicherer.
Und ganz kurz verrühren,
– also jetzt wirklich nur noch kurz, nicht lange –
bis sich alles verbunden hat.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Ich finde, der Teig sieht optimal aus,
riecht gut
und hat eine tolle Konsistenz.
Den Ofen habe ich bereits vorgeheizt
auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Ich backe das Ganze jetzt in einer Gugelhupfform.
Ihr könnt den auch in einem Backring backen,
falls ihr keine Gugelhupfform habt,
oder in einer Kastenkuchenform.
Das geht auch.
Ich fand jetzt hier nur eine Gugelhupfform richtig, richtig schön.
[Musik]
Und dann fette ich jetzt die Form
mit Backtrennspray.
So kommt man ganz einfach überall dran.
Und...
Ich sage es dir, heute...
Und dann ist die Form schnell gefettet.
Und wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr noch Brotkrümel nehmen,
also Semmelbrösel so zum Ausstreuen der Form.
Muss nicht sein, aber könnt ihr machen.
Ich finde, dadurch hat es aber eine tolle Konsistenz so
am Rand,
so ein bisschen knusprig.
[Musik]
Und dann den Teig hineinfüllen.
Vielleicht noch zur Info:
Das waren jetzt keine backfesten Schokodrops,
sondern einfach nur Schokoladenstreusel.
Da gibt es auch so einen Kuchen,
der heißt Ameisenkuchen.
Da sind die auch mit drin, weil es eben
irgendwie aussieht wie so kleine Ameisen im Kuchen.
Kann ich auch gern mal machen,
wenn ihr den sehen wollt.
Und die finde ich immer megalecker im Kuchen,
weil die einfach auch so schön weich dann sind
und sich megagut verteilen.
Also da, muss ich echt sagen,
bin ich voll der Fan von Streuseln im Kuchen.
Okay.
Und jetzt wird er schon gebacken.
Und ich backe den jetzt, wie gesagt,
hier im vorgeheizten Backofen.
Was ihr auch machen könnt,
falls ihr die Bosch-Serie 8 habt
– da gibt es nämlich den Backsensor.
Den zeige ich euch gleich mal.
Da könnt ihr einfach den Kuchen in den kalten Ofen schieben,
den Backsensor einschalten
und müsst dann nicht mehr drauf achten, wann er fertig ist.
Ich mache es jetzt natürlich so ganz traditionell,
dass ich für euch die richtige Backzeit habe.
Aber, wenn ihr den Backsensor habt,
schaltet sich der Backofen ganz automatisch von alleine ab,
wenn der Kuchen perfekt gar ist.
Also ihr braucht dann keine Stäbchenprobe mehr,
müsst keine Zeiten mehr nachstellen
und habt einfach immer die perfekte gleiche Konsistenz.
[Musik]
Den Backsensor findet ihr hier unter "Menü"
"Assist".
Dann geht ihr auf "Kuchen, Brot und Pizza",
geht dann auf "Kuchen".
Und es ist ein Kuchen in einer Form, also hier.
Und dann steht hier direkt: "Backsensor Automatik".
Tipp: "Form auf Rost, Höhe 2".
Und fertig.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt.
Den kann ich hier schon mal rauslösen.
Ta-da-da-daa!
Ist er raus?
Ja.
Also ich habe ihn echt komplett in der Form abkühlen lassen.
So ist er jetzt perfekt.
Und ihr könnt ihn entweder so lassen
oder noch eine Glasur drauf machen.
Ich mache jetzt eine Zartbitterschokoladenglasur drauf.
Ich habe hier jetzt auch schon
200 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade fein gerieben.
Und jetzt müsst ihr die Schokolade gut temperieren,
damit sie später schön glänzt und
sich kein grauer Schleier bildet.
Deswegen hier zwei Drittel abmessen
und ein Drittel.
Die zwei Drittel kommen hier direkt in eine Schmelzschale.
Und dann direkt hier erwärmen.
Und hier habe ich das Wasser schon kochen lassen,
habe den Herd wieder ausgestellt.
So verhindert ihr auch ein Überhitzen.
[Musik]
Und wenn die Schokolade geschmolzen ist,
nehmt ihr sie vom Herd herunter.
Also jetzt hat sie so ungefähr um die 50°C.
Und damit sie jetzt wieder herunterkühlt
auf circa 30°C,
gibt man jetzt eben das restliche Drittel dazu.
Gern auch schon mal das Kokosöl.
Kokosöl dient jetzt hier dazu,
dass die Schokolade nicht mehr zu fest wird
und beim Anschnitt die Schokolade eben nicht so bricht.
Und so habt ihr gleich
die perfekte Weiterverarbeitungstemperatur.
[Musik]
Noch ein bisschen Geduld, Josh, noch ein bisschen.
Ein paar Stückchen sind noch drin.
Aber dann wird sie auch perfekt.
Gut. Jetzt ist die Kuvertüre perfekt
und ich lasse sie jetzt hier direkt über den Kuchen fließen.
Jetzt ist die Kuvertüre perfekt
und ich lasse sie jetzt direkt über den Kuchen fließen.
Am besten setzt ihr den wirklich auf ein Abkühlgitter,
darunter natürlich ein Blech zum Auffangen der Kuvertüre.
Dann einmal hier über den Rand.
[Musik]
Ich überlege gerade, was ich schöner finde:
Wenn der Kuchen noch durchguckt
oder wenn es komplett bestrichen ist?
Wofür seid ihr?
Josh?
>> JOSH: Ich glaube, auch so nur halb bedeckt.
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht? Sieht schon schön aus so.
Was sagst du?
Sieht auch gut aus, gell?
Ach, ich lasse den jetzt so.
Ich wollte ihn eigentlich echt so komplett einstreichen, aber
es sieht schon gut aus so.
Was sagst du, Aylin?
Aylin würde ihn jetzt ganz bestreichen, gell?
Ah!
>> JOSH: Der Phil sagt: "Mh."
>> SALLY: Na toll!
Mh.
Ruf schnell Sarah!
Sarah hat das Fotoauge.
Sarah!
Okay, Sarah ist die Stimme.
Okay, Josh hat auch ein Fotoauge.
Entschuldigung.
Ich wollte nicht...
Ich brauche nur kurz dein Fotoauge.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Was sagt dein Fotoauge?
Den Kuchen komplett bestreichen
oder so runterlaufen lassen?
>> SARAH: So runterlaufen lassen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aylin, du hast kein Fotoauge.
>> AYLIN: Ich gehe nur nach Geschmack.
>> SALLY: Aylin geht nach Geschmack,
weil sie will halt am Rand komplett überall Kuvertüre,
so den Knack der Kuvertüre.
Das ist schon
– also das war auch kurz so mein Gedanke.
Aber ich lasse es jetzt so. Ja?
Alle einverstanden?
Und jetzt streue ich hier einfach noch Krokant auf die Torte,
Haselnusskrokant, weil es perfekt passt.
Dann macht Sarah kurz Bilder.
Der Josh macht auch schöne Bilder.
Und dann probieren wir den Kuchen.
Und bei dem Kuchen ist es wirklich so,
der wird von Tag zu Tag saftiger und besser,
je mehr er durchzieht,
der Kuchen.
Und
dann probieren wir jetzt gleich.
Okay, Josh, mach einfach die Kamera aus.
Kurz einen Schnitt.
[Musik]
Und die Schokolade da unten bitte nicht wegschmeißen,
sondern da gibt es auf meiner Seite
ganz viele Resteverwertungsideen, wie zum Beispiel
>> SALLY & JOSH: Rocky Roads.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Da einfach so Salzbrezeln rein und Marshmallows
und gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren.
Und dann könnt ihr die Kuvertüre einfach weiterbenutzen.
Ja.
So.
Jetzt machen wir Fotos.
[Musik]
Also die Sarah hat jetzt wunderschöne Bilder gemacht
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: – hoffe ich.
>> SARAH: Ja. Ich habe sie dir gezeigt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ich habe bei den Bildern
schon gedacht, der sieht so saftig aus.
>> SALLY: Ja, finde ich auch.
Warum trägst du eigentlich mein Hemd?
Ist das ein Fetisch?
>> SARAH: Nee.
Weil
mein Oberteil
>> SALLY: Trägst du auch sonst Sachen...
>> SARAH: nicht videokonform ist.
>> SALLY: Ah, okay. Okay.
Ja, komm. Wir probieren jetzt.
>> SARAH: Manchmal ziehe ich
>> SALLY: einfach meine Sachen an?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh, okay.
Gut zu wissen.
Oh wow! Das war ein bisschen zu groß.
>> SARAH: Ich liebe immer den Boden von so einem Kuchen.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ich immer außen
>> SARAH: Das bisschen so das Harte dann am Rand.
>> SALLY: das mit Schokolade.
Hm.
>> SARAH: So das Knusprige.
>> SALLY: Doch, ist schon gut.
Ich wollte kurz sagen,
dass es mir zu viele Schokostreusel sind.
>> SARAH: Innen drin hast du Schokostreusel?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ah!
>> SALLY: 200 Gramm, mehr Schokostreusel als Mehl.
>> SARAH: Oha!
>> SALLY: Das Schwarze da, das sind die Schokostreusel.
>> SARAH: Ja, jetzt, wo du es sagst,
es sieht schokoladig aus.
>> SALLY: Also von daher...
Also wenn man es...
>> SARAH: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Ist gut, gell? Ist genau perfekt.
Ich wollte es auch kurz sagen,
aber nee, es ist perfekt.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also probiert den Kuchen gern mal aus.
Und der bleibt auch wirklich mehrere Tage saftig,
wenn ihr was übrig habt.
Natürlich bleibt wahrscheinlich nichts übrig,
weil der ist sofort aufgegessen.
Und
dann probiert ihn einfach aus
und
ladet Fotos davon hoch.
>> SARAH: Und ladet uns ein.
>> SALLY: Und ladet uns ein.
>> SARAH: Wir essen mit.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ich schreibe Sarahs Kontaktdaten direkt hier unten rein.
>> SARAH: Nee,
bitte nicht.
Ich weiß, was für eine Nachricht dann aufploppt.
Mit dem Namen zensiert.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
[Musik]